Why don't you share this?
I got a seat for you right here.
I appreciate it.
You do? On your face?
We're just gonna go to the beach after this.
Why are you encouraging these Frenchmen?
It's gonna be a good time. We'll bring a full pool.
Give us a one-bite review. Here we go.
It's not a pit we're gonna win.
It's a competition for a t-shirt.
We're gonna build something in the second half.
Do you have well water in your house?
I might need a nap.
Those burritos look fire.
Did you get tacos?
Cheese, steak, fries.
No, this isn't new kit.
This is for a t-shirt.
Your tortilla is pretty shit.
You've done this to yourself, man.
Also, also, also, man.
Your boots fucked me.
I wore your boots to get your t-shirt.